and then uh let me try to
introduce professor cham um
i'm so glad to um introduce uh
professor chan here he is an assistant
professor in the department of
computational and applied mathematics
at rice university after receiving
his phd from university of texas at
austin in 2013 he served as
postdoc advice university from 2013 to
and at virginia tech from 2015 and 2016
before returning to rice as faculty in
2016.
his research focused on accurate and
efficient numerical solutions of
time-dependent partial differential
equations which is
very much of our interest and his recent
work has focused on the construction
and efficient implementation of provable
stable
high order methods of wave propagation
and fluid
flows okay today professor chan is going
to
talk about entropy stable schemes for
non-linear conservation laws
higher order discontinuous scalar key
methods and reduce the total
so no further due
here you go professor chan you can still
thank you very much i appreciate it uh
thank you very much for the introduction
and
uh very much of the invitation to speak
it's great to
see many of uh familiar faces and names
show up in the
in the zoom chat window uh so
i will broadly be talking about two
different things in this talk so it'll
be
largely split into two where i tried to
introduce what an entropy stable theme
is
and then try and show how i can apply
this to higher order dg methods
and also to reduce order modeling and
kind of the same framework
um so i should mention before i start
that this is of course not work that
i've done alone i've been very lucky to
work a little bit with my postdoctoral
advisor tim warburton
on some of the results here and i have a
wonderful team my postdoc mario and uh
student philip wu they uh they have
worked on some results that i'll mention
but most of the uh results that i'll
talk about have been done by these two
graduate students yemen lin and
christina taylor who like whose
contributions i really appreciate
okay so let me try and set the stage for
what i am interested in broadly i do
computational science i do simulations
and most uh most the recent work i've
done is spoke on aerodynamic
applications
so exterior aerodynamics where you want
to resolve acoustic waves
vortices turbulent behavior or shocks
and what i generally want is to be able
to achieve high ac
levels of accuracy on very complex ish
geometries so
i might be interested in looking at
unstructured meshes in order to resolve
something like this trifoil over here
but because of this and because all of
my mentors have generally worked in this
direction
i have been using discontinuous caloric
methods which give you geometric
flexibility in high order for relatively
relatively easily i've been using this
as my primary numerical simulation
technique
and i'd like to describe a few reasons
why they're nice
why they're not so nice and how this
recent work on trippy stability i think
addresses some of these underlying
issues
so what am i actually interested in
these simulations i
like the fact that these distant tuesday
methods can be made high
order in a fairly easy way just to
illustrate the effect of
order of accuracy if i take a first
order method say an upwind finite volume
method for the advection equation
and just try and simulate a gaussian
kind of going
round and round in a periodic domain
then eventually after a few revolutions
you get this behavior here where
everything diffuses out
if i increase the second order then you
see much better behavior there's a
you still see some some diffusion of the
solution features
but everything is much better resolved
by just going up one order
if i were to go up two more then you can
see this dissipation further decreases
and if i go up to eighth order then you
can see that there's virtually no
difference at all between
the ejected solution and the exact
solution
uh and in each of these cases i don't
know if you can tell but
i'm decreasing the number of degrees of
freedom i'm increasing the order but
decreasing the mesh resolution
as i go on from first to second to
fourth to a so that i have the same
number of degrees of freedom
everywhere so this is a purely academic
example
it's uh something you would show in a
class but it's not too hard to
extrapolate this
to some more realistic applications
these are not my results a result from
andrea beck and gregor gaster and
apparel off pearson
but i think they illustrate the power
that high order has for exterior for
cfd type problems so on this top row you
have
the taylor green vortex at uh several
resolutions so
again they are keeping the same number
of degrees of freedom for each uh
each method but here they have second
order and
the second picture is fourth order and
this last picture
is at a whopping sixteenth order and in
each case you can see that as they bump
the order up the red uh the vortices
that you see are resolved more uh
uh to with my accuracy same for this uh
this is driven kel helmholtz and
stability you can see
that these features in the interface
these fine vertical features
those would be fairly hard to resolve
using a low order method and
parallel person uses an eighth order
scheme in order to get good resolution
in terms of discontinued scholarly
methods versus finite volumes or finite
elements
i mainly use discontinuous scholarly
because i find them very easy for
explicit time stepping if i want to
simulate
if i want to simulate a system of
equations using explicit time stepping
then for finite element type methods i
have to invert
the mass matrix at every single step
well for higher order finite elements
this math matrix
is globally coupled but sparse for a
higher order dg method this math matrix
is block diagonal trivially invertible
it makes the implementation a little bit
easier okay
so that's the usual boilerplate that you
might hear for a
discontinuous galerkin method but i also
want to tell you why i
haven't been using higher order dg
methods for a lot of my uh
synchronic relations in cfd up until
recently so
if i run berger's equation then with a
certain initial condition this initial
condition will develop a shock
and for the exact pollution this gives
you a
continuity but if i run this using a
higher dg method i see oscillations
if i continue to run this then these
oscillations grow
and eventually they blow up and your
simulation crashes and this is what
really plagued me for the
first couple of years i tried to use
higher dg methods for cfd
that they are highly non-robust by
themselves if you don't apply additional
stabilization or artificial viscosity
then they generally blow up
whenever they encounter under-resolved
solutions and
things like shocks and turbulence which
are prevalent everywhere in cfd
are highly under-resolved solutions most
of the time
so this motivated me to try and look for
something different and i feel like i
found this a couple
years back when i learned about entropy
stable high order schemes
i wanted to avoid i want to avoid the
common
metrics used for higher schemes which
was to apply some sort of solution
regularization to avoid blow up and to
improve robustness so
in practice this amounts to adding some
artificial viscosity filtering the
solution
or applying slope limiting techniques
from finite volumes and while these all
generally work fairly well they can tend
to reduce the amount of
the accuracy that you that you achieve
and if you want to gain that accuracy
back by reducing the amount of solution
regularization
then you might lose robustness again and
so in my mind
it ends up being a sort of tightrope
walking scheme where
you have robustness on one hand higher
accuracy on the other
and you're basically trying to tune your
stabilization parameters to make sure
that you can achieve
as much of both as possible but this is
a problem dependent task
discretization dependent task it ends up
becoming a little bit of a chore
so what i believe entropy stable schemes
offer is
a little bit of a little bit more
stability independent
of any solution regularization so if i
don't apply anything
then i can run an entropy stable scheme
and get some reasonable rules for a
for a large class of problems case in
point
again these are not my results these are
results from chiweng
shu gregor gassner's group and a group
at uh
at kaust but all of these are entropy
stable simulations for the compressible
euler equations
for the magnetohydrodynamics equations
and for the compressible navier-stokes
equations where you can see
clear examples of turbulence shocks
vertical structures under resolved
solution features
all of these were run using high order
disc entropy stable schemes
without any artificial viscosity
filtering or slope limiting
so my goal has been to uh basically take
these schemes and to expand them to see
how general we can get with them
okay so i wanted to first finally
explain how these methods work
by looking at entropy conservative and
entropy stability method and then
generalizing from the
structure that arises there so
i'm sure i don't need to say about this
but if you're not familiar with volumes
i'm basically given a grid
i'm trying to approximate the solution
average over each cell
and i basically try to solve the
integrated form of the conservation law
so just integrate by parts or
use the fundamental theorem of calculus
and you can rewrite
uh your constipation law as
so so if i have the flux at the
boundaries well i know that there's
uh the solution is dual valued at the
boundary so i need to find some way to
take a unique flux and what we do is
just replace
this value of the flux at each bound
cell boundary with a numerical flux
so depending on the numerical flux
obviously you can uh
you can end up with a whole bunch of
different types of schemes and the
specific chemical flux that i'm going to
look at are what are called entropy
conservative numerical fluxes
and what they aim to do is to try and
reproduce a little bit of this entropy
stability
theory for nonlinear problems and
reproduce it at the discrete level
so i think of entropy stability if you
if you're not familiar i think of it
essentially as a generalization of an
energy balance for a non-linear
conservation law
so if i have burgers shallow water
equations compressible euler or
navier-stokes equations mhd
they're a class of nonlinear
conservation laws which all admit an
entropy inequality
so essentially what we do is if we have
some convex
entropy function which we can think of
as generalization of entropy
sorry of energy then we can define the
entropy variables
v as the derivative of this convex
entropy with respect to the conservative
variables if i then
multiply the equations by this set of
empty variables integrate over the
domain
then i can do some manipulations and
eventually get that the average rate of
change of the entropy
plus what essentially amounts to the
entropy flux in and out of the boundary
is going to be less than or equal to
zero so if you have a closed domain or
appropriate boundary conditions
this term vanishes and you get that the
average rate of change of entropy is
always decreasing
or always negative so average entropy is
decreasing in time
this is as close as you can get to an
energy type as
four nonlinear problems uh and what
entropy
conservative uh final volume methods do
is they try to reproduce
uh this at the discrete level in a very
specific way
so given our finite volume scheme i will
take this a flux to be
entropy conservative where it has to be
consistent for accuracy
has to be symmetric for conservation and
then it also has to include this very
strange conservation condition
where if i take the difference between
two entropy of entropy variables at two
different solution states
and oops contract that against this
entropy considered flux
then the result gives me the difference
in what are called the entropy
potentials
so if i have this then i can show that
my numerical scheme conserves entropy
in that the rate of change of entropy is
equal to zero
so this isn't exactly the entropy
inequality we saw before but it's not
too difficult
to simply
to simply add some dissipation and if
this dissipation
is uh is constructed appropriately then
we can reconstruct an entropy inequality
at this discrete level at the final
refinery volume scheme
okay so uh
sorry i'm having some trouble moving
these slides around
great so these entropy conservative
fluxes are a little bit more complex
here's an example for the compressible
euler equations in 1d
you have something like the average of
the density multiplied by the average of
the velocity but this average of the
density is taken to be the strange
logarithmic average you also have some
additional strange quantities you have
the inverse temperature beta
you have a logarithmic average of that
as well
um but these are entropy conservative
fluxes in explicit form and these are
going to be the main ones that i've used
throughout this uh this
for all the numerical experiments in
this talk
okay so conservative and entity stable
finite volumes are
they date back to the 1980s and i think
even before a little bit
what uh i really what was interesting
recently was that
uh there were a couple of folks gastner
carpenter
uh chiwengshu and some others who showed
that you can reformulate these
methods using hadamard products and from
there extend things
to a much more general framework so i
the hadamard product of two matrices is
just their entry-wise product take every
single enter the ij to entry multiply it
by the ij's entry the other matrix
and what i'm going to do is take my and
take an endpoint
finite volume scheme i'm going to assume
it's periodic for now so that
the first node is connected to the last
one and i'm going to rewrite it using
hadamard
products so i can think of this as
basically being the difference between
fluxes where these fluxes whoops sorry
are going to be evaluations of this
entropy conservative flux at two
different solution states
so you can see that you have difference
between the first flux uh the first
and second flux uh the first nth flux
the second and third flux the second and
first flux
so on and so on so
if i write this in hadamard product form
what i can do is i can
combine all these fluxes into one giant
flux matrix
where this just involves the evaluation
of fluxes between every single solution
state in the boundary
and take the hadamard product of that
with a matrix which essentially samples
and scales
all these individual flux contributions
for a periodic scheme
it looks like this matrix which you
might find a little bit familiar if you
work with different type methods
so if i go a step further i can call
this matrix 2 times q
i can call this flux matrix f and i can
rewrite the right hand side of this
entropy conservative finite volume
scheme
that's simply the hadamard product of q
times f
multiplied by the vector of ones so this
is just going to be
essentially summing up over the columns
of this hadamard
product so this is a kind of
cute representation but why is exactly
is it useful
well it turns out that writing it in
this way it's a little bit more
generalizable
we can take our entropy conservative
finite volume scheme i'll treat the
entropy
stable the sort of entropy dissipative
case later
we can write it in this semi-discrete
form
and if i define m to be basically the
scaled version identity matrix involving
the
the mesh size then i can look at m
inverse times q and see that that's
actually a second order differentiation
matrix for a periodic domain
and the key observation which i will use
in this talk is that
i can actually show any method of this
form
is entropy conservative so long as q is
either is both skew symmetric
and conservative in order in other words
q times this vector of all ones
is equal to zero so we'll use this to
extend to high order dg methods and
eventually to reduce order modeling
but first i want to mention so this is
for periodic domains if you actually
want to treat boundary conditions it
turns out that this is not too difficult
you simply have to replace sku symmetry
with what's called the summation by
parts property in the finite difference
world so we'll impose boundary
conditions in the usual way by choosing
appropriate ghost values
and these ghost values will be
multiplied by some boundary matrix which
scales
your contributions at the left and right
end of the domain and
our relevant q matrix in this case will
then
uh be this matrix which looks like a
center difference
except for the first and last rows which
are first order differences
so this q matrix satisfies what's called
a summation by parts property it's
related to this boundary matrix in the
following way
to basically mimic integration by parts
and if you do that then
you can show that you are still entropy
conservative or entropy stable
uh when you add dissipation
okay so the main innovation behind this
just to give you a sense for
some of the challenges later on is that
we can reproduce this chain rule-based
entropy identity
where we take this volume integral and
turn it into essentially an entropy flux
through the boundaries
we can reproduce this fully at the
algebraic and discrete level
and the key step in this is utilizing
this entropy conservative property of
this flux
so if i take the skew symmetric form of
this contribution up here
then i can expand it out and see that
it's actually going to be the entries of
this q matrix
multiplied by oops sorry exactly
this jump in the entry variables
multiplied by this
entropy conservative uh flux and that
we can root sorry that we can reduce
down to this quantity involving entropy
potentials
and the proof is relatively
straightforward there
okay so the first generalization that uh
other folks
uh figured out earlier on was that you
can extend this to high order summation
by part schemes
pretty trivially so let's say you take a
nodal
uh discretization a spectral type
discretization where your
nodal points are placed at gauss loboto
points
well if you define a nodal
differentiation matrix using lagrange
polynomials
then you can show that well this has
zero row sum so d times one is equal to
zero it's conservative
and also if you multiply this matrix by
the lumped mass matrix for gauss's
bottom point
then you also get the summation by parts
property so this allows you to construct
entropy conservative schemes
in 1d you can extend to higher
dimensions using a tensor product
construction
and this has largely been the workhorse
of most of the practitioners who
use entropy stable methods nowadays
we can also extend to multiple elements
not just a spectral element but multi
high order dg by essentially adding and
using this entry conservative flux as an
interface flux
within our formulation so we can now
using this uh combined the previous
slide in this slide
uh create the higher order dg method
which is entropy conservative for
arbitrarily high polynomial degrees
and if we add some pretty common
interface dissipation like lacks
friedrichs
then it turns out we can show things are
actually entropy stable as well
okay so this has been a long review but
i want to try to
set the stage for essentially the work
that i was i've been
uh interested in looking at and my main
contribution has been
looking at this one word modal to try
and generalize
these entropy stable schemes from nodal
and from summation parts planet
difference type uh schemes
to more general modal dg formulations
and i should probably explain what i
mean by modal so if i use the nodal
dg formulation well i'm essentially
assuming that i'm using a very specific
set of nodes on a very specific basis so
for example uh gauss lobato nodes and a
lagrange basis collocated at those
points
but for a modal formulation i it
resembles much more of the generality of
finite elements where you take any
choice of basis functions whether they
be hierarchical nodal
bernstein so on so on combine them with
any set of quadratures
and end up with a reasonable scheme so
before until recently this wasn't
it wasn't possible to actually do this
while retaining entry stability
so these modal schemes are testing me
because i do a little bit of work on
hybrid meshes
and these modal schemes may make it easy
to automatically apply things not just
to hexes
but to wedges pyramids and also tets
they were also interested in me because
i've done some work on under integration
and uh for nodal formulations they often
under integrate uh
solution and end up with fairly large
discrepancies in terms of uh in terms of
error so you can see that
this dotted line you have an under
integrated solution you lose more and
more accuracy as you increase the
polynomial degree
so i want to get rid of this and more
recently after i saw
some talks from the audience i actually
got interested in
trying to apply this to projection-based
reduced order modeling as well and
that'll be the second half of the talk
so i should probably explain why some of
the what some of the challenges for
modal formulations
actually were our previous uh the
previous construction of
high order entropy conservative schemes
relied really on the algebraic structure
of these collocation type methods
and you can treat them as finite
difference methods you can basically
treat things point wise
when i'm thinking about modal
formulations you have to think in terms
of functions
and that poses your first challenge that
what we want to do is to take our
formulation and
multiply it by the entropy variables
however
for higher order dg formulations this
typically involves taking the test
function
to be equal to whatever you want to
multiply the equation by
but entropy variables aren't polynomial
and our test functions have to be
in uh finite element method so there's a
little bit of a hiccup here
it turns out that this is relatively
easy to uh to account for
in order to get in order to extract out
the right the relevant entropy balance
quantities
so when we multiply our time derivative
by the entropy variable so we want to
get the average
of the average rate of change of entropy
over each element
then we can simply multiply not by the
entropy variables themselves but by
their l2 projection
the l2 projection preserves moments and
so therefore we can show that
this integral here is equal to the
integral without projection
and that reduces down by the chain rule
to we have on the right hand side
so this throws a little bit of a hiccup
though in that because we're using the
entrop
projected entropy variables we also have
to now evaluate all of our fluxes
using these projected entropy variables
so we'll take we'll actually take these
projected entropy variables
re-evaluate the conservative variables
in terms of them
and use that to evaluate our right hand
side if we don't do that then we can't
use this property of entropy
conservative fluxes and our proof of
entropy stability falls apart
so just to briefly illustrate it this is
an example
for a relatively coarse mesh for the
entropy variables for
the compressible euler equations i'm
using degree four approximations
uh eight elements and if i take it into
a solution and i approximate it using a
polynomial
then i get some mismatch near a shock
but otherwise it looks fairly good
so if i transform these to entry
variables then you can see that
over these elements this doesn't really
look polynomial anymore
and so we'll do is we'll project it to
polynomials you can see that there's a
little bit of discrepancy
with this red dotted line those are the
polynomial projected entry variables
and then when we map back to the
conservative variables
we end up with a dotted red solution and
dotted red here and you can see that
there's some discrepancy but it mainly
lies in the vicinity of a shock where we
don't really expect to resolve the
solution very well anyways
okay so this entropy project solves our
first challenge but there was an
additional challenge which i'll try to
describe in brief
uh so for summation my parts type
methods
uh if we choose the nodes properly then
you have nodes which lie
on the boundary of an element and
the design of interface fluxes for
higher dg methods in short
uh you design these interfaces but they
cancel out specific boundary terms in
the discrete entropy balance when you
multiply your formulation
entropy variables you end up with some
terms should all cancel out to zero in
order to get entropy conservation
so because you have nodes on the
boundary you can use
you can use the flux to directly cancel
out those
contributions from those boundary nodes
and everything basically looks like a
regular dg method and that coupling only
happens
through these boundary nodes if you use
a different set of nodes if you use that
or contain only the interior
it turns out that using old entropy
conservative
technologies that you would actually
have to have all to all coupling for
these ddg type fluxes and that kind of
ruins the communication pattern
for these higher order dg methods so i
wanted to fix this
and we essentially fixed this using what
we realized much later
was an old finite element technique of
hybridization
so uh technically speaking what we do is
we take our summation by parts matrix q
and we use it to construct an augmented
block
uh summation my part to operate figure
so this can be used to approximate a
derivative in the following fashion you
can basically
multiply by you can basically project
this onto a galerkin basis
and then multiply by a math matrix
inverse uh
but we've introduced here this couple
this operator which maps between
uh volume nodes and face nodes so this
allows you to
basically uh bridge the gap between your
nodes in the interior and nodes on the
boundary of an element it also turns out
that it's actually a little bit more
accurate as these uh plots appear show
and you can also interpret this type of
matrix as adding a correction term
which kind of looks like the difference
between the extrapolated flux
and the flux and a non-linear flux of
the extrapolated solution
okay so long story short
once we have these two ingredients
constructing a modal dg method
entropy stable dg method is actually
fairly straightforward what we can do is
take our old
entropy conservative dg formulation and
then simply
replace this first term and this last
term
with uh the relevant new hybridized
summation by part
operators so once we do uh what's hiding
behind the scenes is that
this flux matrix now has to be evaluated
using
uh these tilde variables these entropy
projected conservative variables
and one other slight detail is that
i can get entropy conservation so long
as i status
i can get entry stability so long as i
satisfy conservation
and essentially a weakened version of
the summation my parts property which
relates to quadrant accuracy
i won't go into too much detail here but
it's satisfied by pretty much
uh standard finite element type
quadratures
okay so finally some numerical
experiments um
we tried this on higher order dg methods
just to see if things work back in the
day
and we used essentially standard
quadrature rules
from xiaomi and standard uh gauss
quadrature rules for all the face nodes
plug this into the dg method and you get
the following you can run a riemann
problem with
shocks without any
artificial dissipation filtering or
slope limiting and it remains stable
with the only stabilization being
applied uh basically coming from
dg upwind type fluxes
so since then we've tried to move on to
a
lot more areas we've uh could use this
formulation to actually construct
new collocation methods on quad and hex
meshes
we've gotten some new approaches for
non-conforming meshes which
some of our collaborators in germany are
now picking up for their software
we've been working on extend this
shallow water to network and
multi-dimensional domains a coupling of
say 1d
and 2d domains and most recently we've
applied this to the compressible
navier-stokes equation so here's an
example of flow over cylinder
uh at t equals 100 for it reynolds
number 10 000
and mach 1.5 and just to have a little
bit of a nice
uh break from me talking let me share a
quick video
still getting used to there we go
so here's a quick video of this actual
simulation
you can see that uh around the shocks
there are some oscillations so
we don't solve issues like gibbs
phenomena
these are still present but the solution
remains stable despite the fact that you
have these oscillations in your shocks
and
this is run pretty much with a vanilla
es entropy stable dg method
uh degree uh 3 no artificial viscosity
slope limiting
or filtering
okay and
go back to the
great so
uh what i want to do in the remaining
time is really talk about how we extend
this to reduce order modeling and talk
about some of the challenges that we're
still facing
uh with reduced order modeling i
essentially
one of the reasons i want to work on
mobile formulations was because they
were amenable
to reduce order models you can interpret
in a very very naive way reduced order
model
as basically being a a high order dg
method with
very strange uh modal bases on just one
single element
and it was that naive approach that i
first started with
so what we'll do is we'll take off for
uh for those of you who aren't familiar
we'll take a full order solution uh and
essentially try to decompose it into a
set of
modes and these are computed using
proper orthogonal decomposition
or some other similar approach and the
main
idea is that we want to compute these
modes in an offline phase where
things can be really expensive but have
the online phase of a simulation the
actual simulation
for different parameter values be
relatively fast and the goal of this is
to accelerate
many query scenarios like uh
like uncertainty quantification or
design space exploration
so uh reduced order models
are useful in the elliptic and parabolic
regimes or they've been
they have been well established for
those areas because there they
inherit the stability of the full order
model this is not entirely true for
nonlinear hyperbolic problems
and this is kind of the issue i want to
try to look at so again i'm going to
start from a simple method entropy
stable five volumes same as before
and i'm going to just add a little bit
of viscosity so i'm going to
basically just add a laplacian type
viscosity over the entire domain
turns out that this is entropy stable
and
and but i'm going to focus on ensuring
that when viscosity goes to zero
we end up with an entropy conserved
video type scheme
so if i want to apply uh
reduce order modeling to this uh to this
discretization
then i can go through a pretty naive
color can uh pod galerkin procedure as
follows
if i have an offline approach to compute
basis functions
uh from proper orthogonal decomposition
given solution snapshots
then i can basically just uh apply a
standard galorkin projection of this
matrix system
so previously i had m times du dt
plus 2 times q had more product f times
one
i can simply insert
v multiplied by enforce that this
residual is orthogonal to all
basis functions and
essentially if i plug in the entropy
projection step
by introducing this pseudo inverse here
this projection onto the range of the
basis functions
uh then i end up with an entropy
conservative orange should be stable rom
if i have
uh dissipation so
uh one little note that's uh
non-standard here
because i am using uh this set of bases
this set of modes to approximate
both the entropy and the conservative
variables i'm going to construct my pod
basis from snapshots of both the
conservative and entropy variables
combined
okay so i stopped here thinking that
this would work and when i talked to
someone in the new shorter model they
said you're missing the whole point
i essentially have to also reduce costs
for evaluating nonlinear terms
so the cost of evaluating non-linear
terms uh scales with the number of grid
points in the full order model which is
a major challenge
so if i want to evaluate the entropy
projection or if i want to evaluate this
flux
then uh decide the cost of these
don't they still scale with the original
full order model and what we want to do
is try to reduce that
so we adopt a fairly standard approach
hyper reduction where given a grid we
try to pick
relative uh relevant sample points from
that grid either on the boundary or on
the interior
in order to approximate non-linear
evaluations
of this form with uh this following form
here
so what we're doing is we're taking a
non-linear function and evaluating it
at a bunch of grid points and instead
we're going to approximate that
or the nonlinear function evaluated only
at a specific number of hyper-reduced
grid points so
i is going to be this index set which
picks out certain rows
of this basic matrix which course
each row of this basis matrix
corresponds to a different point
we'll then weight these contributions
and then multiply them
by this sampled matrix
transpose so this is something like a
quadrature approximation for a reduced
order model
and you can see multiple examples gappy
pod dime empirical cubature
energy conserving sampling weighting all
of these
uh share a similar structure we're going
to focus on empirical cubicter
and ecsw in this talk though
so the question becomes well how do we
hyper reduce the specific nonlinear
terms in this entropy stable formulation
we have q hadamard product with f which
is a non-standard way of writing
this convective term and what we'll do
is we'll try to hyper reduce this by
constructing a sample matrix q sub
s so recall that if we can
show that this matrix is skew symmetric
for a periodic problem
and conservative then we get entropy
stability or entropy conservation
immediately so the main challenge
starting out was that
most of the common options for trying to
construct a sample matrix would either
do sub-samples
rows and columns of a full matrix that's
sort of a dime-like approach
or to approximate uh this
matrix q to construct the sample matrix
using a weighted sum of local matrices
which is an approach taken by peter and
jano
in this paper down here so the problem
is that with both of these approaches
uh your matrix q s your sample matrix
loses either skew symmetry or
conservation and therefore isn't that
pretty stable anymore
so what we're going to do is take a
different approach where we actually try
to do a two-step hyper-reduction we
first compress the matrix
and then we project onto the compressed
matrix
so our approaches are as follows we try
to construct a modal
differentiation matrix by doing galerkin
projection using an
expanded test basis so think of these
basis functions essentially sampling the
action
of our original differentiation matrix q
we obviously want to make sure that we
differentiate our pod modes v
properly but we also want to
differentiate one exactly in order to
get conservation
it turns out for accuracy we also want
to make sure that we can
accurately sample q times v this is sort
of an lspg type approach if you're
familiar with that
and then we'll just construct the modal
matrix as v transpose
times q times v where v t is this test
basis
okay so now we have a way to express the
action of q
on coefficients in this test basis all
we need to do is find a way to transfer
between hyper-produced points
and these coefficients which we can do
using a quadrature-based projection
operator p
sub t so essentially we use hyper-reduce
points to project onto this test basis
and then if we chain them together by
simply taking the modal matrix and
multiplying on the left and right by
the transpose of this projection matrix
then we get a sampled hyper-reduced
matrix which is accurate
skew-symmetric and conservative and thus
gives us an entropy conservative reduced
order model
so just briefly about this hyper
reduction we're constructing our
hyper-reduced points by targeting
functions which are used to start a mass
matrix and as a technical point
because we're only looking at targeting
using high production to accurately
approximate mass matrix
c's constructed from the pod basis this
expanded test basis
might end up with a singular mass matrix
so what we'll do
is we'll just add some stabilizing
points and i'll show you that these
there's we don't add too many of these
in practice
so these stabilizing points will
essentially target uh
near null spaces of this test mass
matrix
okay so in summary we have this two-step
compress and project hyper-reduction of
this
uh hadamard product non-linear term and
then if we plug that
in to our uh formulation using hyper
reduction
then we end up with uh with a form a
reduced order model which is entropy
conservative
or entropy stable if you add an
appropriate type of dissipation
so this is nice but i should uh
make a little caveat there's no free
lunch this entropy conservative method
uh reduced order model can actually be a
little bit more expensive
than a full order model under specific
circumstances because
we introduced more flux evaluations due
to sparsity
i'll go into this a little bit later
i'm going to skip this slide for time
but essentially we impose non-periodic
boundary conditions in the same way that
we did for dg methods
using the summation like parts operators
and all this requires when adapting it
to a hyper reduction
is to enforce a specific type of
constraint in our hyper-reduction
procedure so i do this using
this linear programming approach of the
tereniano
that is found in this paper
okay so let's show some numerical
experiments
uh this is just the 1d euler equation i
have a viscosity of
2 times 10 to the negative 4 and
i'm just going to run a problem which
has reflective boundary conditions at
the wall so i can show that i can work
with non-periodic boundary conditions
and develops a shock after some time
so if i use only 25 modes and everything
is incredibly under resolved and you can
see huge oscillations
but nothing blows up
are the uh the values the solution the
hyper-reduce points and they look messy
but they don't explode
and in this case with the 25 modes we
add only
three additional stabilizing points if
we increase 75 modes well things start
to look much better we can resolve the
solution
prior to the shock really well and when
the shock hits you can still see some
oscillations in this area here
but again it doesn't blow up and we've
added more stabilizing points but
not too many more if we run with 125
modes then things look like they're
nicely converging
and we're adding only 36 stabilized
points and if we go up to 175 modes
uh then the number of stabilizing points
we have to add is only 28 so
this approach seems to be working okay
we have a growing number of empirical
curvature points that depend on the
number of modes
but the number of stabilizing points
seems to kind of taper off after some
certain
time so one thing we want to test was
robustness uh if we were to run this
with this reduced order model with
wrong parameters or uh incorrect data
how does this perform so we tried to
emulate this by running the same shock
problem
but completely removing viscosity so if
you do that with 125 modes usually this
would blow up
because if you don't have stabilizing
viscosity then reduce on the model can
develop
oscillations which eventually explode in
this case the oscillations are
definitely present they
reveal all sorts of ringing artifacts in
the solution but it doesn't blow up
it's garbage but it is stable garbage is
what i usually like to say
and we can moreover verify that the
actual contribution to the entropy
production
is close to machine precision which is
this right hand side block
okay so if we take a look at the
evolution of entropy
then you can also see that as we
increase the number of modes
the entropy the dotted red line
converges to the
uh the decay of entropy for the four to
model quite nicely as well
okay i also want to check to make sure
this hyper-reduction approach that we
were using that it actually works
here we have an example of errors over
uh this over a certain time period
with and without hyper reduction so the
line is without hyper reduction and the
dots
are with hype i'm sorry the line is with
high production the dots
are without high production and you can
see that in both cases the errors appear
to be basically
the same so despite the fact that we're
hyper reducing everything we don't
have lost accuracy in our reduced order
model
okay so just some examples in 2d here's
a smooth kelvin helmholtz instability
i'm using 400 thousand points for the
forward model
viscosity of one over a thousand
seventy-five modes and
you get this you can see that there are
some differences in the reduced order
model like so there's some
oscillations and striations inside here
but it remains stable
and we end up with a decent 1 relative
error at time t equals 3 which is 75
modes
and the sampling points that we end up
with
we end up with 884 of them and they're
distributed kind of uniformly
by domain so this was a good sanity
check for us
uh we can also do the same thing with a
gaussian pulse in 2d
um we have the full order model on the
left reduced order model on the right
uh and with 25 modes and the
distribution of
hyper-reduce points that looks like this
we end up with entropy stability and
under one percent error so these were
sort of easy cases
um i was also interested in looking at
an under-resolved riemann problem where
you develop a shock
and here you can clearly see that the
reduced order model fails to capture
the shock because well there's a shock
it becomes difficult and uh it's well
known that reduced order models have
performed poorly so you can see a bunch
of oscillations here and here
that show up in the reduced order model
with 50 modes the relative error is
higher
but despite the fact that these
oscillations there they don't blow the
solution up
so we're trying to there are two issues
i think are pretty
uh are difficult for these problems
which is both accuracy and stability
we haven't yet figured out how to
address accuracy there are techniques
that
uh yongsu and others have proposed which
might be useful
we're trying to address stability and
incorporate these techniques for
accuracy and later
okay so this is all the good stuff uh i
should pro oh
and the distribution of points you can
see cluster is pretty much where there's
activity in this riemann problem i want
to
talk a little bit about some of the
downsides of the formulation as well
so with since you have entropy
conservation for a very general set of
reduced order models there has to be
some sort of downside as well
and it's about to show up in two areas
both in terms of singular value decay
and in terms of computational cost so
first if we look at the
decay of singular values uh the red is
uh i'm plotting two sets of singular
values here with and without entropy
variable enrichment
so if i don't add entropy variables to
my snapshots
then i get a singular value decay that
looks like this blue line here
but you can see that both the red line
and blue line are pretty close
up until about um 400 modes and that's
far more than we need to resolve most of
our solutions
for the gaussian pulse you can see that
it's a little bit uh it starts to differ
closer to around 50 modes
but remember that we were able to get
under one percent error
with only 25 modes for this gaussian
pulse
for the riemann problem however it's a
little bit of a different story
we use 50 modes and if we zoom in on
this picture we can see that at 50 modes
there's already a little bit of a gap
between the decay of the singular values
with and without entry variable
enrichment so we are paying a little bit
of a cost
to better resolve the entropy variables
in this formulation
the more pressing problem for us is that
for
at least explicit time stepping it turns
out that the reducer models that i ran
were more expensive than all the full
order models and this is for a simple
reason
when we're computing the main cost for
explosive time stepping is the
evaluation of this nonlinear term this
hadamard product between q
and f which you can write down entry
wise as a sum
of a weighted sum of these fluxes
so in order to save time we usually
compute this on the fly
and if we know that q is far so we know
that certain entries of q are zero you
can skip over those entries and
avoid evaluating this flux for those
entries so for this full order model
uh matrix it's incredibly sparse and
we actually only have about uh uh i
think in this case we have
only about a hundred or two hundred uh
flux of values that we have to do
if we were to compress uh down this four
order model matrix into
sample matrix using pod and hyper
reduction despite the fact that it's
smaller it now becomes fully dense
and so computing this hadamard product
can involve many many more entries
so for explicit time stepping i think
this this puts a little bit of a damper
in terms of the problems that i can
solve using explicit time stepping
and i just want to briefly mention at
the end of my talk what we're doing to
try to address this
so we're looking at shifting to implicit
time stepping where the solution of the
linear system
becomes a little bit more of a dominant
bottleneck and see
we're interested in seeing how reduced
water modeling can uh can
be applied to this context we found
recently that it can be very efficient
you can compute jacobian matrices
for entropy stable schemes in a very
efficient way and i'll just briefly
mention that
so for implicit time stepping we need
jacobian matrices in order to
solve a nonlinear equation at each
iteration
and typically these are computed using
automatic differentiation
if you have a sparse finite element
method you can reduce cost in this
automatic differentiation
by using graph coloring techniques but
these don't work very well for dense
matrices
and ad becomes very expensive as the
size of your normal linear
term that you're trying to differentiate
increases
so what we found recently uh this is
work with christina taylor
is that if i have a hadamard product uh
term
in my entropy stable discretization then
the jacobian matrix can be written in
explicit form as basically
uh the hadamard product between q and
the derivative of the flux with respect
to the sec
argument plus small diagonal correction
and what this does is it basically makes
automatic differentiation efficient
again because
this flux has order one inputs and
outputs and 80 is very efficient when
the size the input and output are
limited
so just to give you an example of uh
speedups
if i have a 50x50 matrix q and i'm
computing this uh hadamard product
uh for the burgers equation then i can
see that the cost drops from
300 mil uh 400 milliseconds to about
3 milliseconds using this formulation
this is a comparison between directly
automatically differentiating
this nonlinear term and computing this
jacobian
using our new formula so
we have this in a preprint and we've
applied it to hydrator dp methods
i am hoping that christina will work on
this for her phd and i hope to
present these to you in hopefully a
future talk
so with this let me summarize our let me
just say
i'm very grateful to the nsf for funding
this uh this work
and if you're curious i have a couple
references down here
so thank you for your attention and i
welcome any questions
thank you so much jess for the wonderful
talk
i think i learned a lot personally
but we are going to have some q a
session um if you
have any questions please don't hesitate
um
you speak out um i i check the chat chat
room um
i see that no no questions i was posted
so please speak out if you have any
questions
oh don't forget yourself hi
hi mike hey this is mike yeah mike
i got a question i really did enjoy the
talk i thought it was great actually
um thank you i do have a question so you
say
you still get some of the phenomenon
right it's still stable i understand
because you know you
you use the right you can show that with
the test functions
um but with the gibbs phenomenon
if you have is it possible that you can
get like negative pressures that will
screw up your equations of state
yes absolutely and so i i usually
mention this in the talk and i apologize
that i've forgotten to
uh but yes every so all the stability
theory here depends on
positivity of thermodynamic variables so
uh if those are negative then all the
stability goes out the window
and we're currently working on different
approaches to fix this
so uh for our
you can fix so there are some existing
positivity preserving limiters which
aren't dissipative which uh you can
apply at least to some discretizations
and we'll work on trying to generalize
this to uh it's
basically some flux corrected transport
type methods but
essentially yeah you hit the nail on the
head this is an open problem
awesome um just add on to that um
you know that issue of the negativity uh
in the context of the video student
model
um there is a non-negative uh
the factorization you can use um in
order to
you know preserve the positivity um if
it can be issued
more more of than issue in the biggest
locomotor context right
um this is of the basis
like non-negativity of the basis
functions of the cod
right right and and forcing the
coefficient in front of it to be uh
positive or non-negative then
you are uh you know preserving the
there okay and any other sense
yeah um any other questions
well in dg yeah you said you could use
you could use like bezier functions
right
you're saying you're going to get rid of
its phenomenon
which would make sense but not all of it
necessarily
i guess maybe again that's at the
pressure the gradients are still to be
negative
sorry so can you see the last part again
well that that would smooth out say the
displacements but that wouldn't
necessarily
but not necessarily the gradients so
that you still could get negative
pressures
the pressures so so i'm trying i'm not
sure where the
where the gradients show up and i mean
so my my our strategy so
far has been if we ensure positivity of
say uh
uh density and and temperature or
density and internal energy then we try
to recover
positivity of uh pressure by jensen's
inequality or some
this is uh some some tricks that gy2
introduced a while back
um i
yeah maybe so i don't know about the
gradient
uh issue that you're referring to can
you okay never mind
yeah i'll think about it sure
sure and uh and yeah so we've explored
bezier in another life when i did my
propagation more i actually uh
worked very very heavily in uh in
bernstein's polynomial representation
we have found that they work very well
but it takes very very careful flux uh
corrective transport approaches which
i know that folks at the lab are very
invested in and have done a lot of work
on
so we we found that they that they could
be used to preserve positivity but
that the coefficients were kind of a
very they were
a sufficient measure but a very rough
like an act inaccurate sufficient
measure at certain times
and i haven't found a way to get around
that really
thank you any other uh questions i mean
it's it's
today's talk was actually on the high
order uh dg
so i i think a lot of um the folks from
the m10 team
uh will have um you know
find it very interesting um
so so jesse i have a very basic question
all right um you
show for at the beginning for a
continuous problem you showed that the
average entropy decreases in time
and then you use that motivated
numerical scheme
where the average entropy is constant
and i kind of don't like that so can you
say something about that
yeah certainly so right so this is uh
um this
is essential so this we only do because
we're assuming that we're going to add
some sort of
entropy dissipation later on um
but we want to try to ensure stability
or at least this
entropy conservation property and the
absence of dissipation as well
uh this is philosophically this i think
is sort of
our stress test but in all of our
simulations i mean we always add some
interface dissipation for dg methods
um or some physical dissipation for the
compressible navigation
problems where we do get that entropy
inequality at the very
end does that help answer a little bit
of the question
it helps a little i'm not sure i really
like it still but um
maybe i just need to think about it some
more well that's no that's
understandable and
so if i were uh i've had arguments with
some other folks uh
jean-luc garmand and uh for example
where uh
yeah there is there are some issues i
think that are associated
with trying to target first entropy
conservation
and then adding entropy dissipation
later on so if you were to use a uh
a more standard lax rejects type box
then
um i think
yeah there are there are definitely some
advantages um
i don't really have a digestive the best
justification i can give
is that if you were to try to enforce
entropy dissipation at the discrete
level then i think you would lose high
order accuracy for these dg methods
so uh the
because we're adding an extra
dissipation
this hadamard product formulation ends
up giving you higher accuracy
and then you add try and add dissipation
to make sure you don't lose
a higher accuracy at the very end that i
think is probably a
better defense of targeting entropy
conservation first
does that make a little more yeah that
helps thanks
okay thanks yeah it's admittedly still
an issue though um
we there are some trade-offs
thank you jess um i think we are our our
time's
up and let's thank uh speaker uh thank
you so much seth um
it was really great talk i i hope that
um
you know you you get to connect it with
a a lot of folks in lawrence people more
as i said
before and you know the you know the
collaboration
is continued um okay uh thanks
so much everyone to uh for joining the
today team
we have another seminar next week um
so please stay tuned and today's
the talk is recorded so if you are
interested
uh please let me know um okay
let's let's add john here thank you
thank you again
thank you for inviting me i really
appreciate the opportunity
thank you thank you jess um um i have a
i have a usually i stay with the clicker
after the seminar uh but unfortunately i
have a
like a follow-up meeting right away so i
have to go
don't worry but i will catch up with you
uh
later um but it was really great talk
um and nice to see uh
you know you're applying the reduced
model for entropy
stable uh the schemes that's
that's awesome um yeah but but did you
the chabel fahad recently um you know
is it preprint or i think it's still
preprint um
he published a paper about the is the
talking about lspd on a stable
you know yeah for under under resolved
solutions right
yeah yeah exactly and i
i think you guys are talking about the
similar theme um with the different
approach
um so i i think you yeah
you might be interested in checking yeah
you already checked that out i guess
i i saw it on archive and i saw him give
it actually i think a virtual talk
somewhere on on it recently um
yeah i i i think we're both interested
in the same approach i
um i think lspg by itself
it already adds a lot of uh just a lot
of stabilization
right yeah which which for i think for a
lot of problems will solve things i
i my impression is that for
so so i was talking with some other
folks and
uh one of the key differences i think is
the metropolitan formulation you have
lspg and it's at the fully discrete
level
whereas this is a galerkin a regular uh
calorical formulation
at the semi-discrete level so there's a
little you you make some assumptions and
some uh
you basically uh fix your type of reduce
on model reduction
uh when you're using uh farhad's type of
approach
that said it clearly will work very well
especially for under-resolved turbulence
i don't know if i saw any shock problems
in that paper
that i'm less clear about yeah i mean it
it it will it will be um it will be
difficult to
to capture the shop uh this rock uh it's
very
radiant um well yeah i'm sorry i cannot
uh stay longer
but uh thank you so much and i will um
let's stay in touch
i'll show you another email soon i i
finished reading your recent paper and
i'd love to talk to you about it offline
sometime
that's awesome okay thank you thank you
jess
thank you take care see you